this luffy half lunarian well there
seems to be a lot of hints pointing us
in exactly that direction but first if
you aren't caught up to the one-piece
manga what are you even doing here go
catch up right now go go go there's
spoilers but if you are welcome luffy's
firepowers have always been a bit of an
enigma in the one piece community ever
since red hawk was first introduced
during luffy's fight with hody
jones can rubber really do this but
looking at the scene now knowing that
luffy actually is a mythical zone fruit
user with the human human fruit model
nika this moment now hits very
differently because we now know that
luffy's powers aren't only rubber but
actually freely shaping the world around
him as he pleases as we can see with his
cartoon powers
wait a second where does the fire come
in here though i mean luffy's hair turns
into flames like yogurt but on the other
hand the reveal surrounding luffy's real
devil fruit has not really cleared up
the fire problem all too much i think
[Music]
the only two explanations i could come
up with is that either luffy is just
able to manipulate the environment to
such a degree that he can just do
anything as we can see with the
lightning bolts or that he's able to
imitate other devil fruit abilities
which would of course be awesome but i
think there might be actually a
completely different twist here after
all
what's up amanu and i was really happy
that a user with the wonderful name of
lc joyboy of my subreddit wild anime
theories kindly messaged me and pointed
out to me that eichiro the author of one
piece might be toying with our
expectations here once again as he loves
to do so often because of course luffy's
strange ability to generate actual flame
fits wonderfully with the image of nika
being the sun god and the sun being a
reappearing symbol throughout the story
now sadly not everyone can have as hot a
hairstyle as luffy i know it's terrible
to think about but two out of three guys
will experience hair loss by the time
they're 35 which is where today's
sponsor comes in keeps i know it is
terrible to think about but two out of
three guys will experience hair loss by
the time they're 35 and keeps offers
clinically proven research-backed
treatments to stop hair loss and improve
hair growth my grandpa for example
bowled it with like 30 and it's honestly
stressing me out a little bit luckily
keeps a subscription service that helps
men with just that keeping their hair
their treatment plans are not only
clinically proven to combat the symptoms
of hair loss and tailored to your
personal needs but they're also pretty
affordable typically have the cost of
pharmacy prices that way you can get
quality expert care without ever having
to visit a doctor's office or pharmacy
as they're delivered straight to your
doorstep and people typically notice
results within six months of starting
their treatment so if that's something
you're worried about hair loss stops
with keeps to get 50 of your first order
go to keeps.com ohara or click the link
in the description that's key eeps.com
o'hara the sun is fire luffy is the sun
god so having fire abilities makes sense
only that as far as his powers have been
explained so far it kind of doesn't i
mean oda has focused just so much on the
gomu gomu sun god nika devil fruit
storyline in the last few dozen chapters
setting up this reveal that it was very
easy to overlook the importance of
another big chunk of lore drop the
introduction of king's lunarian race
here's a quick recap lunarians are a
race of powerful beings with unique
abilities that used to live on top of
the red line despite their incredible
strength the lunarians were somehow
driven into almost extinction with king
being the last known remnants now this
is purely based on king's appearance but
lunarians seem to be almost angel-like
beings they are humans with dark black
wings way larger than those of the other
known sky people and especially through
the lens of oda sensei's love for quirky
characters king is probably the most
objectively seen handsome and perfect
looking male figure in the entire story
so far with long white hair and dark
skin making it a point of presenting the
lunarians as an elf-like or angel-like
race that was almost completely
eradicated for their powers king
oh my god
now interestingly enough the name
lunarian hints at a connection to the
moon which is not only interesting
because of anal's adventure on the moon
and all the lore that seems to be hidden
up there but also because the sun and
the moon are the two main recurring
symbols in the story on top of that king
also has a face tattoo not unlike that
of luffy's father dragon that seems to
depict a flower that is known as
moonwart now that parallel to dragon by
the way would not only make luffy half
sun half moon but also begs the question
to whether it was luffy's mother or
maybe even dragon himself who was
lunarian who knows maybe god valley was
actually the last refuge of the lunarian
race who were known as gods until the
god valley incident happened
because not only were the lunarians
known as gods themselves connecting them
to luffy's sun god title but they are
also naturally able to produce and
manipulate flames with their bodies
similar to how the minks are able to
generate electricity or how the fishman
can manipulate water
[Music]
which of course brings me back to luffy
and his strange ability to create fire
by the way long before ever awakening
his sneaker devil fruit all these lore
drops about the lunarians have happened
at the exact same point in the story as
the hints that luffy's devil fruit might
be special so why give us this backstory
now before luffy's defeat and
reawakening why specifically show us
king's background and not that of queen
or jack we find out that the world
government seemingly hunts lunarians
around the world to this day rewarding
anyone with 100 million berries for any
tip-off about a lunarian's whereabout
just the tip-off not the person itself
and at the same time we learned that
they were trying to get their hands on
the nika devil fruit for over 800 years
so to me that suggests that this is
either related to luffy himself or even
more specifically to the nika fruit
itself
and so who knows maybe the infamous d
initial was actually used for
descendants of the lunarian race kept
secret to not reveal its continued
existence to the world government just a
thought and so luffy being part lunarian
would not only explain his firepowers
but also how he was able to generate
enough heat to awaken his devil fruit
powers as we saw him melting and
steaming at the end of chapter 1043.
what i'm trying to say here is that
being lunarian might be a prerequisite
for awakening the nika fruits powers
which would not only explain why the
government would try to kill off every
single member of their race but also why
they were not concerned with luffy
having the fruit as they didn't know he
had lunarian blood which would actually
be really satisfying i think to me
because that entire plot thread was
somewhat of a loophole i feel like odan
still needs to fix step 1 be part
lunarian part 2 have the sun god fruit
part 3 be worthy to awaken its powers
and part 4 if you're a real mad lad
consider subscribing to the channel
another really interesting detail that
supports this idea is luffy's eyebrows
looking a lot like sanji's in chapter
1044
sanji whose fire powers have now also
been strongly hinted at being based on
lunarian dna who by the way we now see
using blue flames just like kyogros in
the latest cover and who i wanna add was
the very first person to notice luffy's
reawakening before anyone else despite
probably not having better observation
haki than for example marco on top of
all that we have luffy's haki taking on
the form of flames as well there were
also a ton of other interesting
instances throughout the story that now
that i'm looking at it again might be a
lot more important for example luffy not
freezing on drum island an arc by the
way that literally connected the drums
of liberation the will of d and the hito
hito no me
luffy was also literally frozen solid by
aokiji but was completely fine
and luffy generating more heat and steam
the more air he inhales also would work
really well with innate firepowers in
fact this would also fit in very nicely
with the idea that devil fruits have a
will of their own it's one of the
theories i am most proud of because it
seems to be confirmed more and more
every chapter so if you want to take
this to the next level don't ignore this
video right here